finally we get to see gameplay of eldon
ring's first open field area and so much
more this is an incredible preview that
i wish i could have shared earlier just
seeing the character traverse the world
is such a thrill and there are a ton of
small hidden details throughout this
video for example here you'll notice
that ambient music is playing similar to
how it does in secure in front of our
character you can just see these threads
of light which appear to be guiding us
to a nearby site of lost grace since the
open world is so vast these will
probably ensure that you don't just walk
right past one graces are a type of
checkpoint here you can rest replenish
your healing customize your weapon
skills choose your spirit summons and
even summon the fire keeper character of
this game to level you up
i assume this cutscene is set to play
early in the game when you rest at a
grace note that this character appears
out of a gentle blue light phasing into
the physical realm
greetings
traveler
from beyond the fog
i am melaner
considering all of the references to
spirits in the lands between i wouldn't
be surprised if we're between life and
death or between realms in a sense
it's a common motif for the fire keeper
maidens to have a veiled face in some
way and melina is no different with her
hood
i
offer you an accord
an accord is a sort of mutual agreement
according to the elden ring twitter
tarnished to accept melinda's accord
find fellowship here in this place the
new hub world of elden ring but back to
the gameplay in a burst of glowing
leaves you touch this sight of lost
grace and another thin guidance of grace
appears this light seems to guide you
towards your next objective probably
towards the next logical site of grace
the way we quickly mount up while moving
should give you a really good idea of
how the mount might be able to be used
in combat to quickly close a gap
look carefully here and you'll see many
wild animals and materials as well these
resources can be used in item crafting
something seen later in the trailer
the dragon flies in from an insane
distance it goes towards this pyre
surrounded by hollows and he targets
that not you
so this is just one enemy that inspired
a new display design for me which we're
calling guardian of moonlight and i'm
releasing this literally right now 20
off in celebration of this new gameplay
link in the description so check it out
if you need some art for your walls but
i'll talk about it properly later in the
video so this dragon is a field boss
it's one of many found in the open field
area of the game from software mentioned
that these bosses vary in difficulty but
that they are optional so you fight them
at your own risk or benefit this fight
finally showcases how mounted combat
shines against a larger foe where you'll
often need bursts of speed to chase them
down or to avoid larger aoe attacks this
character is clearly using a sorcery
build a horsery sorcery built there's a
joke there somewhere casting while
mounted looks pretty damn powerful right
look carefully and you see the character
casting a soul dart spell at full speed
though it does seem that characters have
to slow down in order to cast heavier
spells dismounting and dealing with the
dragon in melee is also viable
and i'm really curious how they balance
enemies to deal with mounted and
dismounted players maybe the ai detects
that in some way
hello
can you hear me
help me i'm stuck
hello
[Music]
please anyone
oh my stars i'm so happy to see you
i am alexander
also known as the iron fist
and as you can see i'm stuck here
please
can you help me out of this
put those doubts to rest i'll be just
fine
i'm very well trained
give it your all i say
this npc man i have no words discovering
something light-hearted like this in the
open world just gives the game so much
character
ah
well played good sir well played
oh that mighty wallop of yours almost
spelled the end of me
the distance we can see three smaller
herd trees try and find them on this map
that the player pulls out
finally i can show this i adore its
design the contouring the detail and
that sort of parchment style it just
looks amazing at the bottom right you
can see a dial that's displaying the
cycle of day and night
around the land mass on the map is an
ocean or maybe it's the sea of fog that
melinda mentions either way there are
boats and robots upon it you can place
up to 100 markers on the map the symbols
are pretty good able to remind you of
things like difficult enemies somewhere
to return to to explore further or
valuable treasure
some points of interest also appear to
have their own preset markers you can
also press buttons on the map to show
sites of grace you can also place
beacons on the map which show up as
pillars of light in the overworld in the
press demo they appeared numbered on the
compass which appeared at the top of the
screen so it's clear that you can place
multiple of these in this scene the
player runs past a sort of lightning
event here the lightning seems to
generate a bunch of little grace icons i
wish they stuck around to show what
that's about but we have a caravan to
assault and our character is going there
to grab its loot these birds react so
slowly that they can probably be hit
with melee attacks and hunted for
resources these resources can be used in
this crafting screen items show you the
resources you need to craft them and the
resources have a little line that tells
you where you might be able to gather
them here on the right we see a new stat
arcane this is in addition to
intelligence for magic and faith for
miracles souls are now called runes
there's also the return of poise as we
fire a sleep arrow notice that a tense
ambient music has started playing as we
stealthed into the camp once we start
killing combat music plays just like in
sakura apparently killing a sleeping
enemy means that you've left stealth if
this alerts nearby enemies it's probably
a way to balance sleep arrows from just
letting you sleep and kill enemies
easily jumping heavy attacks are great
at breaking enemy guards it's like
breaking their posture basically and it
allows you to perform a critical attack
here the character showcases some skills
these can be freely swapped between
various weapons some of these look
absolutely incredible and as we've
learned from dark souls 3 they have to
be because otherwise people just won't
use them difficult areas allow for the
summoning of helper spirits you can
customize which spirits you'd like to
summon at a grace checkpoint every
spirit has different advantages and
disadvantages for example immediately
after being summoned this mob starts
screaming this aggros way more enemies
which is a negative part of these
summons to offset the fact that you know
there's like six of them it's an
interesting way of balancing things so
since there are only four players max
allowed in one world of eldon ring and
since you're allowed to co-op with up to
two other people in a lot of cases it
seems like that's only going to leave
one spot for an invader additionally
invaders can now only invade players who
are engaged in co-op and not solo
players people have rightfully raised
some concerns about this so it's worth
giving them feedback on that when the
network test airs soon it's worth
reminding you also that falling damage
has been significantly reduced in elden
ring to help you navigate the world as
these characters progress into the
forest listen again to the music it's
suspenseful and foreboding there are a
lot of enemies in this wood and if they
call for help then i bet things could
quickly get out of hand this field boss
is different than anything the press saw
earlier in their preview it looks
incredibly difficult even in co-op which
is great oh and watch this block
animation carefully we've come across a
boss guarding this area did you hear
that sound so that was a sort of block
riposte it's this new sort of counter
that you can do after you block an
attack it has a special sound effect and
this is the first time we've seen a
player do it with a shield equipped
spells look insanely powerful that's
good and they've always needed this kind
of variety so that's great just look at
some of these
if i had to guess the red lightning and
dragon head
are arcane spells that might use the new
stat mentioned earlier
so assumedly this is one of the many
subterranean labyrinths in eldon ring
diving straight from the open world
right into these tightly designed
corridors that sounds awesome the co-op
phantom color here is interesting too
sometimes it looks like they have no
color and other times they're almost
entirely an orangey red it's a pretty
cool effect
this is stormville castle the word vale
as in the storm veils the castle i love
shrine of storms and demon souls so hey
i love how this is shaping up
[Music]
you're tarnished aren't you
i would advise against taking the main
gate into the castle
it's tightly guarded by hardened old
hands
oh
try the opening right here
the guards don't know about it
you'll breach the castle undetected
fair enough
you certainly don't have to trust me
well
if you must go through the gates i'll
signal them to open
but of course i'd advise against it
i'm curious about this character's
allegiance the people of the castle
listen to him yet he's also a bit of a
turn-coat who doesn't fear them as he
brazenly calls for them to open the
gates for us and then guides us to a
secret entrance
having two very different ways to enter
the castle is a wonderful design choice
and this variety consistently plays out
as you explore the castle and see all
the vertical exploration that's open to
you
a lot of weapon skills and spells come
with these associated symbols
basic weapon skills don't but they look
[ __ ] awesome regardless
it's good to see the traditional from
software traps the npc here is the same
type as the character before so what's
their story they all have these
restraints hanging from their necks are
they prisoners now with their hands set
free
overall as a legacy dungeon this is way
more like dark souls except now you have
a jump and as you've seen that will just
change level design in such an awesome
way
this guy has a pretty big hat
ah
nice to meet you
the pleasure's mine
roger's the name
a sorcerer as
you might have guessed
i'm looking for a little something
here in the castle
when i'm not hot-footing it from the
troops that is but enough about me
what are you doing here in stormville
castle
this place is bristling with tarnish
hunters you know
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting not exactly a place i'd
stroll into without a purpose in mind
so this bird is the same one that was
summoned in this screenshot it seems a
lot bigger than its spirit summoned
counterpart so bear in mind that spirit
summons aren't always identical to the
ashes of the deceased that they're
summoned from
mighty dragon
dirty
in this fight with godric we see the
block counter again this time with a
weapon this is a great addition to
combat while you're two handing a weapon
because blocking while two handing was
almost always a terrible choice in
previous games and at least now you have
a way to get back into the combat with
an offensive ability the boss seems to
instantly aggro onto your spirit summon
bosses seem to have quite a few aoe
attacks as well or at least i hope they
do otherwise spirit summons like this
are going to be completely busted this
magic attack lets you charge the sword
which is cool and in this boss's second
phase he seems to get this diseased
dragon head it's the same sort of dragon
design as the one that attacked us
earlier which served as inspiration for
this brand new display design with a
really famous artist if you need
something beautiful to adorn your walls
something that contains a ton of
references to the games that we love
then watch them and thank you for the
support justin garad is a highly
acclaimed artist renowned for his
depictions of dragons and other monsters
his work is nostalgic it's so playful it
has incredible color and fantastic
detail i could think of no one better to
design a dragon disc plate design so
that's exactly what we did this is the
guardian of moonlight it's this enormous
black dragon that dominates a bridge a
common trope in the souls series your
eyes are first drawn up to its skull
silhouetted by a bleeding sun then down
to our protagonist who has been burned
narrowly escaping the same fate that has
befallen other familiar faces piled next
to him his goal of course is a familiar
moonlight but he'll be lucky to make it
there unscathed as always there are a
ton of secrets and references in this
piece so i hope you enjoy hunting them
down you can get this post over 20 off
for a limited time with the link below
so please support this work because i'd
love to work with justin again you can
find links to justin's work in the
description he runs a very popular
patreon page targeted at mentoring
aspiring artists and he has a store of
his own filled with gorgeous hardcover
books drawn by him and his wife also
soul arts my art book is available for
pre-order if you missed the kickstarter
so go and check that out in the link
below as well thank you so much for
watching there's more elden ring content
to come
sooner than you think and i'll see you
then
[Music]
you